[Music]  even if you ask me why why didn't you  left the valley  i don't have any answers  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  but  that's that that was not like that  that the scenes are created like like in  in in such a way  i told you that it's my mindset  and  the entire kashmiri muslims were  seen as  a terrorist  no massacre no massacre of kashmiri  prince  took place before the  majority community  [Music]  here  [Music]  these are our families  there is there are the 808 stories how  they have survived  it it was very difficult for 808  families to survive for last 32 years  or especially in the in the peak of the  mildency  or even today that the way the faceless  militancy is going on  so  foreign  [Music]  you